WELCOME TO THE SENATE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE AND I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM SO LOW
THE SECRETARY.
ALL.
SENATORS GALGIANI HERE WELL DONE
HERE WILL.
PRESENT.
PRESENT AVEIRO HERE [inaudible]
GLAZER.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
AND WE HAVE ONE BILL ON THE
AGENDA THIS MORNING SENATE BILL
ONE FIFTY THREE BY SENATOR WELL.
DEALING WITH INDUSTRIAL HAM.
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND PROCEED
THANK YOU A MAN CHAIR AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING LATE AND
FELLOW MEMBER.
I SB WHAT FIFTY THREE REVISES
THE STATE'S PROVISIONS ON
INDUSTRIAL HIM. TO CONFORM TO
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR STATE PLAN
UNDER THE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN FARM BILL.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE SECRETARY
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD INACTION CONSULTATION WITH
THE GOVERNOR AND ATTORNEY
GENERAL. TO DEVELOP AND SUBMIT A
STATE PLAN TO THE SECRETARY OF
THE US DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE.
ON OR BEFORE JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA
STREAMLINED ASSURE HIM
PRODUCTION RULES HE BECAME
COMPLIANT WITH THE THEN EXISTING
FEDERAL LAW.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF SB FORTINO
NINE WHICH THE CHAIR WAS A
GRACIOUS SO.
CO AUTHOR OF LAST SEPTEMBER
HOWEVER THE PRESIDENT SIGNED HR
TO THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN FARM BILL
IN DECEMBER.
FOLLOWING.
PASSAGE OF OUR BILL.
UNDER SECTION.
A TEN ELEVEN THREE THE FARM BILL
STATE DEPARTMENTS OF AGNES COULD.
CONSULT WITH DATES GOVERNOR
CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER TO
DEVISE A PLAN THAT MUST BE
SUBMITTED TO THE SECRETARY.
OF THE U. S. D. A. THE STATE
PLANS THE STATE'S PLAN TO
LICENSE AND REGULATE HAND CAN
ONLY COMMANDS.
ONCE THE SECRETARY OF USDA
APPROVED THE PLAN.
THE LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZE HIS
IMMENSE BENEFITS AND
OPPORTUNITIES GROWING INDUSTRIAL
HEMP WILL BRING TO THE STATE AND
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
I HAVE SHARED THAT BEFORE SO I'M
NOT GONNA GET INTO IT.
AND CURRENTLY THERE'S ALREADY
THREE COUNTY TO GROW HEMP FOR
COMMERCIAL USE HEARING
CALIFORNIA.
IN MY DISTRICT CAP WILL ALLOW MY
FARMER TO CONTINUE FARMING.
I IS THERE CAN BE CONVERTING
THEIR CROSS FROM -- FROM.
HOW BOUT PHOTO WHICH IS ABOUT
SEVEN ACRE FEET OF WATER PER
ACRE TO INDUSTRIAL HEMP WHICH IS
UNDER?
TWO WITH ME TODAY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ARE BRED.
BORROW.
THEIR SKEWS ME PATRICK --
GUARDIAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HEMP COUNCIL.
AND I DON'T SEE THE OTHER
SPEAKER SO WE WILL CLOSE IT WITH
THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I'M SURE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BRETT -- WITH THE CALIFORNIA HIM
COUNCIL -- IN HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND AS THE SPONSORS
TODAY AND THE AND WE DO WANT TO
THANK THE CENTER FOR BRING THIS
ISSUE BACK AND AND CERTAINLY
WON'T COVER WHAT HE SAID BECAUSE
IS OPENING WAS VERY THOROUGH BUT
JUST TO SAYTHAT.
THE HEMP INDUSTRY AND YEAH SINCE
WE WERE HERE LAST IS GONE FROM
SIX HUNDRED FORTY MILLION TO
EIGHT HUNDRED FORTY MILLION LAST
YEAR AND IS IS EXPECTED TO
EXCEED.
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY BY THIS
YEAR AND SO IT CONTINUES TO GROW
CALIFORNIA'S IN LARGE PART.
BECAUSE OF THIS COMMITTEE A
STATE AHEAD OF THE CURVE ON THIS
ISSUE AND WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO
DO THAT BY CONFORMING TO THE
FEDERAL FARM BILL.
THANK YOU AND IN WITH ME I WANT
TO REDUCE PATRICK DOG IN THE
COUNCIL FOR THE CALIFORNIA.
THANK.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OF PATRICK KAGHAN ATTORNEY FOR
CALIFORNIA HIM COUNCIL.
pLARGELY TECHNICAL IN NATURE IT'S
IT'S GEARED TOWARDS CONFORMING
TO THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
FARM BILL ON AND WHICH WERE
REALLY GETTING INTO COMMERCIAL.
PRODUCTION JURISDICTION HAS BEEN
SEATED BY D. E. A. T. U. S. D.
A..
THEY ARE IN THE MIDST OF
PROMULGATING REGULATIONS SHOULD
HAPPEN LATER THIS YEAR -- AND
LARGELY WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IS.
LAY OUT AND MEET THE THE SEVEN
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS THE THE
FARM BILL NOW REQUIRES.
THAT THE STATE'S MEET IN
SUBMITTING THEIR STATE PLANS I'M
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KIANA VALENTINE ON
BEHALF OF HI ENERGETICS AND VOTE
HEMP THIS MORNING ALSO IN
SUPPORT WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR HIS CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP AND DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
TAYLOR RUSSIA THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU AND TRANSPORT.
MANAGER PAUL SMITH WITH THE ROLE
COUNTIES ASSOCIATION WE DON'T
HAVE OFFICIAL SUPPORT POSITION
BUT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE SPONSORS -- AND THE AUTHOR
COULD TRY TO GET THERE ARE WE'VE
BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS ABOUT --
PROVIDING SOME AMENDMENTS ON
FOUR KEY PRINCIPLES -- WITH THAT
WE BELIEVE WOULD MAKE THE BILL
STRONGER AND BETTER PARTICULARLY
IN CULTIVATING COUNTIES.
THOSE OBVIOUSLY -- VAULT LOCAL
CONTROL.
WATER CONSUMABLE HEMP PRODUCTS
OF WATER QUALIFIED RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS.
AND ULTIMATELY OF THE THE
COMPLETE REGULATORY AUTHORITY OF
CDFA ON THE SO WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND
HOPEFULLY COME UP WITH A REALLY
GOOD PRODUCT.
THAT MAKE SURE WE HAVE A
CONFORMITY WITH THE FEDERAL.
GOVERNMENT AND USDA SO LOOK FOR
THOSE CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS QUESTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
I'D LIKE TO BE ARE ADDED AS A
PRINCIPAL.
MY COULD.
THANK YOU.
SEC.
HELLO.
SB ONE FIFTY THREE THE MOTION IS.
TO RE REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR SPELL DONNY AYE DADDY I
WILL BUY WILL I EVER GYRO
[inaudible]
I GLAZER.
WITHOUT YOUR BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES BUT WE WILL GO AHEAD HOLD
THE ROLE OF THEN AND NOW WE CAN
ADD.
THE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AND
GRADUATION THANK YOU
.
I WAS NERVOUS I'M [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
RIGHT.
ARE YOU WRITING.
NO NOT THAT I KNOW OF I THINK IT
[inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE [inaudible]
HE LATER [inaudible]
YEAH
.
OKAY WELL THE SECRETARY PLEASE
LIVE CALL AND CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SB ONE FIFTY THREE
MOTIONS.
CREATION SENATOR GLAZERS.
RIGHT THANK YOU THAT BILL IS OUT
THAT INCLUDES THE BUSINESS OF
THE AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE